[Musique]
je le répète puis je vais répéter tout
le temps c'est important de rester un
but important à chaque jour de mériter
la confiance des québécois s'est jamais
gagnée pour toujours donc pas
d'arrogance on reste un qui on écoute
les québécois
alors monsieur legault qui je vous ai
présenté ce petit extrait pour montrer
qu'il a dit il ya déjà ses troupes ne
faut pas non plus avoir l'air d'avoir
gagné la coupe stanley ce n'est qu'un
match
n'empêche une grosse victoire pour la
cac
martine michel bon soit c'est une grosse
victoire pour la caq contourne ça
n'importe quel bord et c'est une grosse
défaite pour le plq
5e et gros est fait pour le pq martin
deux gagnants trois perdants
effectivement c'est une grosse victoire
pour monsieur le goût là honnêtement
si on regarde le candidat présenté par
le pq une vedette comme pierre nantel on
aurait pu s'attendre à ce que ça marche
et comme franchement on s'attendait à ce
que le pq avait jusqu'à la dernière
minute plus peut-être
réussir là surtout avec la semaine
difficile
que monsieur legault a eu cela dit c'est
sûr que ça fait un état des lieux à six
mois des élections pour les parties de
pulsions qui ont perdu ils vont devoir
revoir leur plan de match très
certainement on dit souvent politiques
qu'on gagne ces élections à cause de la
faiblesse de ses adversaires et là
vraiment les trois partis d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale n'ont pas fait le
poids devant monsieur legault à l'aïe
ont six mois pour revoir
lors des cloches qui sonnent ouais c'est
tout alors même qu'ils sont nichées way
oui oui c'est alarmant en particulier je
vous dirai pour le parti libéral le pq a
quand même maintenu son store ce une
défaite c'est vraiment pertes lourdes le
pq a pas moyen de perdre des comtés mais
pour les libéraux je pense que c'est
encore plus plus inquiétant la 7%
c'est vraiment dramatique ça veut dire
que dans l'ensemble du québec
francophone les libéraux sont
pratiquement
exclu de la course alors c'est un pan
d'un considérable et il ya un problème
de leadership je pense au parti libéral
ce qui m'a frappé je sais pas si vous
avez remarqué dans le dernier sondage
léger il ya moins de la moitié des
électeurs libéraux je pense et 45% qui
voit en madame anglade le meilleur
premier ministre comme monsieur legault
c'est une lettre comme monsieur duhaime
tous les conservateurs pensent qu'il
ferait le meilleur premier ministre
c'est la même chose pour gabriel nadeau
dubois mais dans le cas de madame
anglade et dans le code encore pire dans
le cas de pierre paul st pierre
plamondon
les électeurs de leur parti ne leur font
pas vraiment confiance
alors à partir de ce moment là il ya un
gros gros problème
oui inévitablement quand sa voix si mal
comme vous dites -2 7%
suffit il de porc garder la chef ou de
chef lieu de bons choix commentaire
analyse / hier soir d'abord d'abord en
blanc beaucoup madame anglade monsieur
plamondon produits score madame anglade
en lui disant elle a fait des erreurs à
l'attenté d'avoir un vote plus
progressistes de détendre ça soit son
son éventail d'interventions sur les
francophones la culture la
l'environnement c'était peut-être moins
de choses à faire elle aurait peut-être
dû rester sur ceux de votre traditionnel
des libéraux moi je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord je pense que ce qui arrive au
parti libéral serait arrivé de toute
manière c'était le garde du corps du
fédéralisme avec la disparition du pq on
n'a plus besoin de gardes du corps du
fédéral dessine donc ça c'est la
première raison la deuxième raison les
grands partis ces fonds doit pas juste
au québec dont le biais de voir en
france au début de la semaine pourquoi
les bases sur lesquelles s'appuyait le
libéro s'appuyait sur le patronat lippi
qui s'applique sur les syndicats les
associations communautaires et locales
ne ce n'est plus comme ça ça n'est plus
comme celui signé en france maintenant
c'est plus partagés entre les parties
l'a4 présent beaucoup le patronat mais
parfois les syndicats la cac et un
gouvernement de droite à signer les
conventions collectives les plus
généreuses de l'histoire en éducation et
en santé il ya plus les mêmes
lignes de partage que vous vous dites
lui que s'intéresse à pas ce qu'on
attend beaucoup puis je posais la
question madame anglade iliad est libre
hockin ou pac 10 on n'a plus de repères
michel devait donc c'est plus on dirait
qu'elle a peur de dire qu'elle aime le
fédéral et son drake est la peur de
défendre le cégep dans ce n'est la perte
de faire ceci cela avait trop se
rapprocher du vote national et on est
perdu le qu'il dit peut-être tout ça
mais dans le fond c'est plus profond que
ça mais le message est peu clair dans le
commandement et glane le prenez par
exemple de nationalisme oui c'est très
bien mais aussitôt qu'on arrive dans des
cocons créés par exemple la loi 21 e
hôte sse la sait plus trop où est ce que
devrait aller de la même chose pour la
langue elle a fait un fait le parti
libéral du nord faire un virage
progressistes au dernier congrès écouter
lost a rendu qui était plus plus à
gauche que les solidaires en
environnement même chose l'on se lance
là 100 milliards pour lui de voir les
jeunes vers les gens je pense les
libéraux sont déboussolés et je
comprends ce que le deal il ya des
lignes de fond qui ont bougé pas un peu
partout en occident mais encore faut-il
que le message soit clair et dans le cas
des libéraux il ne l'est plus oui il ya
aussi un problème qu'elle a bien
identifié aujourd'hui madame anglade
elle parlait beaucoup d'économies mon
message économique ne passe pas et ça
c'est vrai et il ya probablement une
partie de son électorat que voter pour
les libéraux dans marie-victorin en 2018
qui passait à la cape pour cette raison
là parce que la figure économique là
l'image économique du parti libéral on
ne la reconnaît pas et c'est quand même
le parti qu'a eu cette étiquette du
parti d'économies pendant longtemps mais
là il a compris avant la caq faisceau
exactement alors assez c'est pour ça
qu'elle aussi aujourd'hui et ciblée ce
message là mon message économique ne
passe pas elle est beaucoup plus elle
s'est positionnée comme un parti de
gauche verts et elle ne pas vraiment
placée là sa position économique oui oui
très bien mais il n'y a pas aussi si on
élargit le cercle un moment
l'elysée qui avait dit les québécois on
l'a on veut leur moment alors les
québécois francophones veulent leur
maman go point à la ligne le res il
reste des grenailles michel et l'udc bah
écoutez ça fait quatre ans que ou
presque les khakis les québécois sont
satisfaits de l'accueil il ya aucun
moment où la caq a paru ébranlé je
comprends que ça a été difficile au
moment de la pandémie mais la confiance
dans la cac s'est maintenu à peu près de
façon constante et et même au cours des
derniers jours que je comprends qu'ils
aient eu des gros tacle sur la question
des chs lb mais de façon générale je
pense les québécois ont déjà fait leur
opinion sur la gestion générale de la
pandémie par la cac tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que ça m'a l'été dans
les chu celle des mais au total je pense
que l'opinion que les gens on est
positive et c'est pas parce qu'il ya un
courriel je sais pas 8 avril qui était
arrivé que ça va faire l'échangé légende
idée je pense que comprend que
l'opposition fait son travail et
travaille fort c'est un journaliste vous
quand même et les journalistes mais sané
brasles point la confiance dans le
gouvernement non mais un devoir de pour
l'histoire d'avoir exactement d'affaires
chez vous êtes d'accord avec ça aussi
mais l'udc à partir du moment où il ya
mme yan bonne symbiose en tout cas une
relation forte en clé le vote
francophone et monsieur legault est ce
que d'autant plus madame anglade je
parle de madame anglais ne devrait pas
être elle même totalement pas essayé de
se créer une nouvelle personnalité pour
les libéraux lui mais je pense que quoi
qu'elle fasse c'est un moment très
difficile à passer pour les oppose sur
moi j'imagine pas le parti libéral
disparaître boss il va se resserrer sur
quelques comtés à montréal qui vont
toujours voté pour lui le parti
québécois va aussi s'appuyer sur une
base de 1 2 3 4 5 conti dans l'est du
québec mais il faut reconnaître que
monsieur legault s'est pas simplement
qu'il a trouvé le juste ton tu sais
qu'il est extrêmement chanceux il
s'appuie sur un ensemble de
circonstances économiques jamais vu au
québec
un chausson le taux de chômage le plus
bas de l'histoire qui entraîne des
pénuries il ya des pénuries de main
d'oeuvre des pénuries de main-d'oeuvre
force les employeurs dont le
gouvernement a augmenté les salaires
alors que ses compotes du tout programme
de la caq d'augmenter les salaires force
le gouvernement la coved a forcé le
gouvernement à procéder à des embauches
massives et à des bonifications par
exemple dans les cpe dans les
maternelles 4,1 en éducation ces
bonifications là ne faisait pas partie
de son programme il bénéficie d'une
chance inouïe en plus c'est arrivé avec
les poches pleines parce qu'ils étaient
avec les milliards de dollars de surplus
8 milliards et survit dans le
gouvernement libéral 8000 à l'économie
va mieux que jamais les milliards contre
oui et il était paix qu'est ce donc il
peut nouer une relation de confiance
avec beaucoup du vote nationaliser
jacquet se disent c'est pas demain matin
référendum de toute façon donc alors il
ratisse large martin on l'a souvent dit
puis on verra là qu'est ce que ça quel
genre de campagne on aura au québec dans
six mois mais on verra oui là je lève
les petits mots sur le troisième lien
qui se divise en deux martin ou deux
petits tunnels quoi qu'est ce qu'on
comprend rien un peu on fait on fait le
ménage avant l'élection je tenais un oui
appuyé le projet dans sa forme actuelle
c'est à peu près impossible pour
monsieur le goût de partir en campagne
électorale avec ce projet-là excès c'est
un projet de 8 à 10 milliards ce qui est
présentement dans les cartons c'est le
projet le plus gros le plus cher le plus
important que la caq a dans ses cartons
ayant parler le moins possible c'était
même pas dans son discours d'ouverture
il ya quelques mois il n'en parlait pas
alors il fallait absolument que ce
projet-là change et même à québec dans
les radios si je peux me permettre je
rajoute il y avait deux bémols à cancon
soulevait c'était le prix ni la date de
livraison 2031 un jour
rapidement là tu michel et luc soûlé ben
je vous parlais des caribous avant de
partir ben écoutez le projet sur le plan
technique le voit est facilitée
j'imagine le plus grand tunnel au monde
le sait c'est un peu prétentieux
et peut-être faisait bon c'est pas
finalement exactement ce qu'est ce qu'on
va découvrir suez mais sur le fond ça
change pas grand chose que les voitures
passent dans deux tunnels plutôt que
dans une sas a change rien à l'étalement
urbain et ce alors les objections de
fond que des gens ont contre ce projet
le vont demeurer welte je n'ai pas pu
dire le projet quand même
on dit qui va être moins cher mais non
on se demandait ce que ça va être un
autobus avec une voie partagée des deux
tours vont l'utiliser 4 de true blood
sur hbo l'homme et que d'abord il y
avait un projet de tunnel puis
maintenant chercher après on cherche
justification et après on cherche sa
forme d'habitude c'est le contraire
protection des caribous est ce que c'est
la prochaine bataille
fédérale-provinciale tu guilbeault a dit
il faut que je m'entends avec québec la
loi sur les menaces sur les espèces
menacées m'oblige intervenir je
m'entends pas que québec je m'entraîne
d'autres martine qu'est ce qu'on
comprend deux ça comprend que le
gouvernement de la caq tarder parce
qu'il devait y avoir une stratégie de
protection du caribou en 2019 le
ministre puis que je précise que le
ministre pierre dufour c'est pas celui
qui est le plus performant du
gouvernement je précise parce que c'est
c'est quand même assez connu ici à
québec il reporter sans 2021 et là il ya
décidé qu'il leur portait à nouveau et
l'a finalement il ya commencé une
consultation qui commençait aujourd'hui
et cette stratégie devrait on devrait la
voir un jour peut-être en 2024 donc dans
un autre mandat et ça c'est sans compter
que ce ministère lol à la rumeur qui
court depuis le début du mandat c'est
qu'on pourrait le faire exploser c'est
dire qu'on enverrait la forêt aux
ressources naturelles on enverrait la
fonda l'environnement et on enverrait
les parcs ou tourisme alors que
restera-t-il de ce projet là
encore une fois sur le gr10 apprend un
équilibre entre le développement et les
caribous on y est bon michel david du
québec est moins pressé qu'ottawa de
défendre les caribous ça c'est clair et
monsieur dufour à la moins précis que
tout le monde au sein de son
gouvernement mais martin a parfaitement
raison m la faune avec la forêt c'est
comme mettre l'énergie ressources avec
l'environnement des liens conflit
d'intérêt patent le ministre est pris
avec deux obligations qui sont
fondamentalement
inconciliables et en plus c'est pas un
très bon politicien alors si on donne à
ottawa l'occasion se mettent le nez là
dedans il est clair qu'ils vont sauter
sur l'occasion aux meilleurs beaucoup de
gens un peu comme quand on parle des
intrusions en sentez vous savez il ya
beaucoup de gens très nationaliste mais
très progressiste qui se disent quand
même des fois heureusement que la loi
canadienne sur la santé pour empêcher
les gouvernement de privatiser ci et ça
mais dans ce cas ci les espèces menacées
c'est de pouvoir que le canada à ottawa
l'udc c'est la troisième fois au moins
que le fédéral remonte les bretelles du
provincial là dessus a eu la haine la
rainette faux grillon ya eu le projet
laurentia d'ailleurs dans le cas dans le
port l'agrandissement du port de québec
où c'est le fédéral qui a imposé l'arrêt
l'homme et nahio le caribou forestier
montagnat le ministre julien ne veut
rien comprendre il est arrivé à refuser
les projets de protection territoire du
ministre de l'environnement est arrivé
en augmentant de 3 % des droits de cours
des mêmes dans les forêts anciennes en
disant oui mais à cause d'eux à cause de
la chenille machin je ressens vont me
revenir la tordeuse épinettes à quoi
s'attendent les épinettes on doit donner
plus de territoire de coupes aux
entreprises il y a aujourd'hui il est
question d'arrêter des publi sac on le
transcontinental dit que ça va mettre
fin à dix coupes forestières dans la
région que nos gars me mène à fermeture
d'une usine de papier alors on est une
occasion en or on a une occasion en or
de cully sur la déforestation on n'a pas
besoin de ces emplois là de toute
manière on va reparler c'est bon vous
êtes passionné c'est très bon adieu donc
on va reparler au cisr des des publi sac
là vous êtes un autre panel de 18h30 je
vous le dis je le dis tout de suite ça
lui a bientôt le plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit